lo que espero hacer en este vídeo es
generar una sensación un poco más
intuitiva de la probabilidad vamos a
utilizar un ejemplo muy común vamos a
tirar un dado justo que tiene seis caras
así es que los posibles resultados son 1
4 5 o 6 y digamos que nos preguntamos
cuál es la probabilidad de tirar tirar
un número que sea menor o igual a 2 para
sacar esta probabilidad como tenemos 6
posibles resultados como es un dado
justo estos resultados son x probables
entonces ponemos un 6 en el denominador
y de todos estos resultados sólo estos 2
el 1 y el 2
satisfacen esta condición entonces la
probabilidad de que esto suceda es 2
entre 6 o si simplificamos esta fracción
lo podemos escribir como 1
pero también podríamos preguntarnos cuál
es la probabilidad de tirar
mirar un número que sea mayor o igual
que 3 y otra vez tenemos 6 resultados
posibles
ec y probables y de todos estos seis
resultados ec y probables cuántos de
ellos involucran tirar un número mayor o
igual a 3 pues están todos estos que son
1 2 3 4 entonces la probabilidad de
tirar un número mayor o igual a 3 es 4
sextos o simplificando esta fracción dos
tercios entonces que es más probable
tirar el dado y que nos salga un número
que es menor o igual a 2
o tirar el dado y que nos salga un
número que es mayor o igual a 3 pues lo
podemos ver aquí aunque hay la
probabilidad de tirar un número que es
mayor o igual a 3 es dos tercios
mientras que la probabilidad de tirar un
número que es menor o igual a 2 es
únicamente un tercio así es que es más
probable tirar un número mayor o igual a
3 que tirar un número menor o igual que
2 pero además no solo es más probable
sino que es dos veces más probable dos
tercios es el doble de un tercio y lo
podemos ver aquí también de los seis
resultados ec y probables cuatro de
ellos son mayores o iguales que tres
mientras que únicamente dos de ellos son
menores o iguales que dos si es que
tirar un número mayor o igual a tres es
dos veces más probable que tirar un
número menor o igual que dos porque
tenemos cuatro contra dos y tal vez tú
llegas y me dices
y sal ya entendí si la probabilidad de
un evento es más grande que la
probabilidad de otro evento por ejemplo
si es el doble entonces es dos veces más
probable que suceda este evento a que
suceda este otro pero cuál es el rango
de probabilidades y cuál es la
probabilidad más baja que podemos llegar
a tener y cuál es la probabilidad más
alta que puede tener un evento vamos a
empezar con la primera pregunta qué tan
baja puede ser una probabilidad
baja
puede ser una probabilidad cuál es la
probabilidad más baja que te puedes
imaginar para cualquier cosa vamos a
empezar haciendo un pequeño experimento
porque no nos preguntamos cuál es la
probabilidad de tirar
un 7 ok tirando un dado justo de seis
caras obtener un 7 pone una pausa al
vídeo e intenta responderlo por tu
cuenta
bueno pues tenemos un dado de seis caras
las seis caras son equis probables y en
cuáles de ellos tenemos un 7 pues sin
ninguno de estos resultados tenemos un 7
entonces la probabilidad de tirar un 7
es cero porque pues en los dados de seis
caras no tenemos ningún siete y qué pasa
cuando te encuentras con una
probabilidad igual a cero pues lo que
esto significa es que es imposible que
suceda
en ningún universo puede suceder algo
que tiene probabilidad cero así es que
es imposible
imposible y ahora vamos a ver qué tan
alta puede ser la probabilidad cuál es
el mayor valor que puede tomar una
probabilidad
entonces nos podemos preguntar por
ejemplo por la probabilidad de tirar
y dar cualquier número entre entre 1 y 6
aunque podría ser el 1 el 2 el 3 el 4 el
5 o el 6 pues cuando tiramos un dado
justo tenemos 6 posibles resultados x
probables de los cuales cuántos están
entre 1 y 6 pues todos están entre 1 y 6
cierto entonces tenemos 6 resultados que
cumplen con este criterio y 6 sextos es
un entero entonces si alguien dice que
la probabilidad de que algo suceda es
cero es imposible que esa cosa suceda
mientras que si alguien dice que la
probabilidad de que suceda algo es igual
a 1 entonces esa cosa seguro sucede
entonces la mínima probabilidad es cero
y la máxima probabilidad es 1 y no hay
probabilidades negativas y tampoco hay
probabilidades mayores a 1 y bueno tal
vez estés pensando en hey
yo creo haber visto probabilidades más
grandes que uno bastante más grandes y
eso se debe a que podemos ver a estas
probabilidades a todos los números entre
0 y 1 como porcentajes el 1 lo podemos
ver como el 100% y así como no podemos
tener probabilidades más grandes que 1
si vemos la probabilidad en términos de
porcentajes no podemos tener una
probabilidad que sea mayor al 100%
aunque no podríamos tener por ejemplo
una probabilidad de 110% lo cual sería
equivalente a tener una probabilidad de
1.1 ahora también hay algo muy
interesante aquí porque hay muchísimas
cosas que nosotros podríamos pensar que
seguro suceden
cuando en realidad si existe una
posibilidad super baja de que no sucedan
o podemos creer que algo es imposible
que suceda pero en realidad no es tan
imposible por ejemplo uno podría pensar
que mañana seguro va a salir el sol sin
embargo no podemos estar 100% seguros de
que eso va a pasar lo que podría suceder
algún fenómeno galáctico loquísimo que
hiciera que ya no saliera el sol mañana
no sé igual y llega un objeto gigante y
choca contra la tierra y hace que ésta
deje de girar y entonces mañana ya no
sale el sol ese tipo de sucesos
inesperados tienen una probabilidad
super baja sin embargo no es imposible
que suceda y por lo tanto la
probabilidad de que mañana salga el sol
no es 1 o keith si nos estamos
preguntando cuál es la probabilidad de
que mañana
mañana salga
sol yo no diría que esa probabilidad es
1 porque no estamos seguros de que eso
va a suceder creemos fuertemente que si
va a suceder pero no estamos seguros más
bien yo diría que esta probabilidad es
algo así como punto 99 99 y pondría un
montón de nueves por cierto no una
cantidad infinita de nueves porque otra
cosa curiosa esto no es muy intuitivo
pero si pusiéramos aquí puros nueves que
se repiten infinitamente hacia la
derecha
ese número es igual a 1 entonces más
bien yo pondría muchísimos nueves pero
en algún momento me detendría la
probabilidad de que mañana salga el sol
es una probabilidad súper alta es casi
igual a 1 sin embargo no es exactamente
1 por creer porque existe la posibilidad
de que llegara una cuásar y nos lanzará
una tormenta de rayos gamma y nos
hiciera explotar
entonces mañana no saldría el sol y lo
mismo sucede para muchos eventos que
parecen imposibles porque hay por
ejemplo la probabilidad de que mi
mascota huesos escriba una gran novela
huesos es mi adorable mascota y
muchísimas personas dirían que es
imposible que escriba una gran novela
sin embargo no podemos estar seguros de
que nunca va a suceder porque tal vez si
hubiera un montón de mascotas como
huesos y todas se llamarán huesos igual
y alguna de esas mascotas y podría
escribir una gran novela estaría
realmente muy chistoso ver a huesos
escribiendo en una laptop y obviamente
yo no creo nunca en mi vida haberlo
escribiendo sin embargo no hay nada que
nos asegure que eso nunca va a ocurrir
entonces yo diría que tiene una
probabilidad de 0.00 000 0000 y pondría
muchísimos muchísimos ceros por aquí y
de hecho voy a poner unos puntos
suspensivos y después de muchísimos
muchísimos ceros pondría un 1 entonces
esto no es exactamente imposible pero si
es muy cercano a imposible que hemos
visto en este vídeo
si una cosa tiene una probabilidad más
grande que otra cosa entonces es más
probable que suceda por otro lado el
valor más bajo de una probabilidad es
cero y el valor más alto de la
probabilidad es uno y además por ejemplo
cuando tenemos un volado de una moneda
ajusta la probabilidad de obtener un sol
es un medio y bueno si tenemos un evento
cuya probabilidad es mayor que un medio
entonces es más probable que suceda a
que no suceda y si tenemos un evento
cuya probabilidad es menor que un medio
entonces es menos probable que suceda o
sea lo más probable es que no suceda